most of us ride this train everyday we
not we say hello
but how much do we really know about
each other
[Music]
it's my first time on a commuter train
I'm sorry have we met
no I'm Joanna but what if I asked you to
do something that could profound the
effects of individual on the street I
don't understand it's just one little
thing someone on this train does not
belong all you have to do is find them
why would I do it
in the bathroom there are $75,000 that
money is yours if you do this one little
thing
I thought this was hypothetical you have
until next stop to decide what kind of
person are you
Michael Michael McCauley they're
watching
I am NOT gonna do this look outside
southeast corner don't make me hurt
someone you love it's all over the news
there's a witness was it deep with the
wrong kind of people
if identified someone on this trains
gonna kill him
who are you what do you know
you have no idea who you're up against
I'm done playing games
[Music]
now everyone does
I'm not gonna let them hurt you
she's trying to set me up we have a
hostage situation take them out you stop
this train now
I asked you to do one little thing
[Music]